[Music]
indeed want this conference
on the future of europe to give as much
sound as possible to the
vision we have for another
european union, we must seize this opportunity
to also bring our
vision into the chorus of the
debate  will be within forums then be a
very
performant and very open digital
platform where all citizens within
certain limits will have the opportunity
not to leave them behind
i think the digital platform and neuro
and huge potential because it
fits the times of today
where many people
seize the opportunity to debate with each other via social media
, we assume that there is
a possibility that another
european union will emerge from this debate and then that
seems to me to have enormously powerful
potential for a real debate with the
citizens of the european union
diffuser is in your hand is a your
hand
[Music]